[Music]
welcome back everybody
to yank speaks it's your favorite
co-hosts that are not named andrew yang
you've got zach brownman and carly riley
which we do every thursday we're coming
at you live from
st mucha not live coming at you not live
from saint lucha you're right we're
coming at you from st
and because we're on vacation and we
would we want to do this on the beach
but the water was too loud and the audio
wouldn't work so you're stuck our lives
are too fabulous we're too fabulous
we're not very not about um but we are
on vacation and it's wonderful and here
we are working hustling so today's pod
wanna do three things first of all in
the news today it's a lot about
afghanistan it's a lot about hurricane
ida
first thoughts and prayers going into
everyone that is
navigating that situation but we're not
a thoughts and prayers podcast we're a
podcast of action so wanted to highlight
a few charities that are doing excellent
work helping those in need right now
podcasts of action so we'll talk about
that number two there was a fascinating
article written by matthew iglesias or
on matthew iglesias sub stack keith
humphreys keith humphries talking about
the changing demographics both of who's
getting arrested in the united states
and
our who is doing the arresting what our
police force is looking like and
something that's not getting covered we
wanted to dive in and then in
conjunction with that number three
there's a program in georgia
that is
teaching cops how to do jiu jitsu
and the results are mind-blowing in
terms how effective they are um in a
number of different ways so want to
break all those down and it's a topic
that's not getting a lot of air cover
when everybody in the world is talking
about a whole bunch of things and we
want to bring you something new
am i right carl are you ready dive in
let's dive in starting with charities
what's going on in the world
yeah um so you had highlighted some of
me that airbnb is doing some really cool
work to help people host refugees from
afghanistan yeah so people may have seen
this headline which is that airbnb
agreed to allocate 20 000
residences spaces etc for afghan
refugees but on top of that they have
now opened this program up so that if
you are an airbnb host or even if you
are not you can now go on and through
airbnb
offer up a spare bedroom a spare house a
spare apartment whatever for afghan
refugees so it's something you and i are
looking into we have a spare room we're
very fortunate so we're very interested
in putting that out there and seeing if
somebody needs a home in new york um and
i would just encourage others to check
that out we'll share the link below
but i really feel very strongly that we
have a moral obligation to
help people who are escaping the taliban
right now for reasons that were somewhat
u.s created not entirely but somewhat
u.s created certainly it's it's
airbnb.org
refugees but if you go to airbnb.org you
can find it
bill maher did a rant saying that
americans should welcome afghan refugees
with open arms and then he joked that
everybody is agreeing with that saying
everybody that's not me should open
their doors to refugees and carly and i
like well
if we can we should so we're going to
try to i don't want to stay here like
we're definitely doing it because we
haven't gotten there yet it's um
we also see if there's you know if
there's need in new york city right part
of this issue like geographic like where
are yeah afghan refugees ending up but
we're gonna try and if not we're gonna
donate so um i encourage you guys that
um i think it's a good source of real
action and if you do want to donate uh
irc the international rescue committee
committee i believe it is the irc um is
a good organization to donate to uh if
you want to help afghanistan without you
know opening a home or if you can't open
a home um so that's a sam harris
actually highlighted that on his podcast
and then the second thing our thoughts
and prayers are out to everyone who's
been
who's had to evacuate who's had their
home damage from hurricane ida this is a
bad one
um and
there's a number you got to be careful
with disaster relief charities because
uh they can spring up and then basically
just steal your money um
but the
disaster relief organization i've always
loved is something called team rubicon
i'll put the link in our bio but what it
is it's these ex-marines who came back
with all this like combat training and
want to use their practical good and now
both themselves and then they train
other former
military vets who have combat experience
and they attack disaster relief like you
would attack like with army tactics if
you will um
hyper effective good use of costs and
good use of like let's call it talented
people on the ground helping those in
need so team room rubicon is what it's
called
we'll put the link in the bio they have
a special
donation link you'll see for the
hurricane victims um
right now so
anyway
podcast of action this is what we're
doing we encourage you guys to not just
say thoughts and prayers and not just
tweet thoughts and prayers not just post
on your instagram but actually donate um
or give something and give your time so
that's our encouragement that's how
we're starting the podcast today
do something good second thing we want
to talk about is
something that matthew iglesias sub
stack highlighted which
in our opinion carl not getting enough
press there was a port report earlier
this year from the bureau of justice
statistics but i did not know existed
frankly the bjs
and it had a crazy stat it was the main
takeaway is that hispanic americans were
slightly less likely to be jailed than
white americans in 2019
um
so basically the rate of probation in
2000
and the rate of being on parole was um
substantially higher in 2000 than it was
uh in 2016 to 2019 it's going down so
you have a
i'll make sure i get this number right
the
by 2016 the probation disparity had
disappeared and the parole disparity had
shrunk by 85 percent between hispanics
and whites the hispanic rate of being
incarcerated decreased by 60 percent
since 2000 and furthermore in this
article there are now more hispanic cops
basically between 1997 and 2016 the
proportion of police officers who were
black
remained stable so in those 19 years you
didn't see a proportionate increase in
black cops however the there was a huge
proportionate increase in the number of
hispanic cops it was 61 percent
um
and so
this article and keith humphries in this
says that this helps to explain why you
had
you know a rise in the number of
hispanics who were expressing either
quote a lot or quote a great deal of
trust in police um i think you have the
numbers on that but it was like 49
of hispanics said that they
had a lot or a great deal of trust in
police and so for context that's still
obviously less than 50 percent uh but
white americans
say uh
have trust in police at a level of like
56 so you're 49 versus 56 percent is
not a huge gap um and whereas
african-americans black americans
trust police at rates of like 27 percent
or say that they have a lot or a great
deal of trust in police at about
is that
in politics in particular and in the
press you hear a lot about
black and brown communities and
their either frustration
injustices dealing in dealing with our
criminal justice system which of course
have been true but by the numbers you're
not looking at that equally distributed
across races you're looking at it where
the hispanic population are seeing more
hispanic cops and more trust um
for those cops and therefore over time
less arrests um of hispanic well
you made that causational and it could
go the other way like who knows which
direct like which comes first right
therefore is not the word i want but so
we've got three things happening at once
right which is you have more hispanic
cops you have higher rates
you have more hispanics saying that they
have a lot of trust in cops
and you have fewer hispanics being
jailed
less than you have white americans um
which is is really interesting and i
think there's political ramifications
here like the reason
that we want to talk about this is
because
from a strategic perspective i think it
it
i hate to say it but like further makes
the case against the defund the police
movement
um
there's i think a tendency as you just
said zach to lump in black and brown
people when we're talking about defund
the police where some of these
call called more radical criminal
justice reform initiatives uh and i
don't think that's actually reflective
in fact by the polling numbers it's not
reflective of what
many brown communities are feeling or
thinking
so there's a press narrative on defund
the police and that it's um driven by
black and brown voters and i think those
numbers are wrong um i don't think
they're wrong i know they're wrong
because here they are um so usa to usa
today did a poll in may of this year um
i guess it was con they released it in
may it was done in march but in this
year it said 18 only 18 of respondents
supported the movement known as defund
the police and almost 60 say they oppose
it um so white americans and republicans
are much more likely to oppose it only
28 of black americans support it and 34
of dems support so um
why we bring this up
the reason this election was close the
2020 election was because
biden thought he was going to roll in
florida and he did not and the biggest
reason was miami-dade county which has a
strong hispanic population and if you're
looking at
data that's saying
there's a stronger trust with the
hispanic community and the police
department and a large democratic
movement to defund the police there's a
disparity there and the democrats are
going to lose if they don't focus on
that and it's fascinating to see
frankly your point carly the political
ramifications of this and what it means
for the future
now
i'll jump in and say none of this is to
say that we don't have major issues with
police brutality or that things are
great i mean again we're we're we've
49 of hispanics say they have a lot of
trust for cops like that's
that's still less than half of the
community um so the other thing we
wanted to do on this show is talk a
little bit about maybe some solutions
that are out there and i want to shout
out our listener kevin say i apologize
if i'm pronouncing your last name
incorrectly but credit to you you
commented to me about this or to us
about this in one of the youtube
comments and then you followed up on
twitter so i want to say thank you for
bringing this to our attention which is
thank you of bjj which is brazilian jiu
jitsu
um
the way that brazilian jiu jitsu is
being used to train police officers um
in
i want to call it hand-to-hand combat
but i feel like that sort of gives the
wrong impression because this isn't just
really being used in combat
yeah yeah so the first thing i want to
say to maybe kick this off zach and then
you you can dive in with some of what
you've learned on this is what i found
really fascinating is police forces
today are have mandatory training when
it comes to using a gun which makes
sense but they are not required to go
through any sort of training when it
comes to
how to handle someone
physically by hand
so
and that is the much more common
scenario than needing to shoot somebody
so it's it's sort of no wonder that you
see these scenarios where you have cops
like
punching people beating people i'm not
justifying it at all but
when you're in this live situation and
you've had absolutely no training on how
to handle it
you're going to see outcomes like what
we see so that was what initially got me
really excited about
this bjj and these trainings uh is i i
think that there's clearly a gap right
now in the way that we're training our
police forces so on the presidential
yang talked about jiu jitsu for cops
which sounds a little ridiculous you're
gonna make all the cops black belts or
whatever like it sounds stupid but um it
sounds terrifying if you're somebody or
straight yeah i mean if you think that
cops inherently
join the force because they have a
violent streak and they want to be
violent towards people this may sound
terrifying i'm of the impression that
most cops
are not do not join for that reason
don't want to hurt people but just have
not been given the tools they need to
successfully handle particular
situations and so end up
doing something really bad
we've talked about this in this podcast
for is that
so the defund the police movement is
like
on one hand
in many local cities it's the largest
budgetary expense right um does it seem
and if it's not working then defunding
makes it go you know like you shouldn't
be pouring more money into a broken
program but that said there is a really
interesting argument to be putting more
resources into better training um
and development of our police officers
and the average training in the united
states for a cop is about 21 weeks
which sounds like a decent amount of
training but that's about what i got um
[Music]
frankly being a lifeguard um like just a
little more and then being a hairdresser
is two years oh my god
nothing against hairdressers i know i
think it's important to have to know
that but cops
the point is that
um cops should have more training so
um
so what's crazy about so here's what how
we got in this jiu jitsu thing so our
supporter kevin flagged this for us and
then brian gumbel on hbo real sports did
a whole special on this um and here's
the stats from this because it's crazy
so they did this
in uh marietta georgia where was it yeah
i think that's
georgia um
and 95 of the 145 police officers have
opted into this thing
um and they get one class a week and
here's what they saw
injuries to suspects
were reduced by 53 percent so someone
was a suspect of a crime compared to
what they were normally in the normal
injury rate for a cop arresting someone
or tracking someone down that decreased
by 53 and injuries to officers down by
about the same percent 48 so safer um
and you were 200 more likely to get
injured by a non-jujitsu officer so what
they were talking about in this piece
was like we're not talking about being
able to like
karate chop your way to knock someone
out it's
it's the boring stuff in mma fighting
it's headlocks and holds
um
and grips and i actually i talked to
some folks who have been trained in
martial arts and i think part of what it
is too is if you feel like you're in
control of a situation you're going to
be calmer as an officer yeah which means
you're laughing
i can destroy you
right like we're talking about headlocks
which can sound violent but you're
talking about a safe non
injurious non-lethal way to subdue
somebody so that you as the cop feel
like okay
i i feel i know my training i can handle
the situation so there was actually
video footage in this bryant gumbel
piece of an officer who was arresting
somebody who used their jiu jitsu
training and who who then started
talking to the suspect they had on the
ground and saying hey you're going to be
okay you're going to be okay and they
interviewed that officer afterwards and
said was that something you you ever
would have done prior to this bjj
training and he was like never but i
felt calm because there's also just a
mental
breathing etc component to mixed martial
arts is that i felt calm and i felt in
control so i felt like i was in a place
to
actually reassure this the suspect which
was
fascinating i will link to the bryant
gumbel piece it's really worth watching
[Music]
hey real talk real quick how is your
mental health mine hasn't been great in
the pandemic post-pandemic it's getting
better and that's why andrew and i are
proud to say that betterhelp sponsors
this podcast because better help is a
very easy way to get
professional counseling done securely
professionally online so whether it's
something interfering with your
happiness or something preventing you
from achieving your goals for me i talk
to my therapist i call it like pulling
off my steam valve i just talk about
just let off a little steam and talk
about everything we're navigating in the
world so you can send a message to a
counselor at any time you can start
communicating under 48 hours it's not a
crisis line it's not really self-help
but it's professional counseling done
securely
online and it's available across the
world so whether you're struggling with
depression or professional issues or
anger or stress or family i got plenty
of that although i love my fam um
relationships or sleeping or self-esteem
you name it anything you share is
confidential you can talk about all
these things conveniently professionally
and affordably in all 50 states
nationwide so
i want you to start living a happier
life today i want you to take charge
your mental health today and as a
listener of yank speech you're gonna get
10 off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang so join over one million people
taking charge their mental health again
that's betterhelphelp.com
yang
[Music]
so then the data on this in this study
which was done by independent like
university
is wonderful 77 percent less tasers um
they're just using their taser less
less officer injuries as i mess less as
i mentioned less suspect injuries and
the other thing
it's cheaper like if we want if we're
going to support the defund the police
it's actually cheaper so they're saving
a net savings of forty thousand dollars
forty one thousand dollars in this
program um
and they did it for 95 officers so
um and there was one the other the full
transparency there was one training
injury so one of the 95 officers got
injured in training it is you know it's
combat um
but
this to me seems like we should be doing
all over the place which it sounds
ridiculous it's like let's teach them
all to be black belts but realistically
that's kind of what we want we want that
like calm zen yoda master to take charge
of a situation
and separating it out i mean going back
to my point earlier not to be a broken
record but like
if most of what cops are dealing with
is having to put their hands on a person
the fact that they are not being trained
on how to safely and competently put
their hands on someone is
if you take it from that angle this
makes all the sense in the world right
like of course we need to be teaching
cops how to do something that they are
going to face
with 100 certainty at some point during
their career as a cop
um now the last thing i'll say and they
say this in the bright gumball piece
right we're we're not saying this is a
catch-all this is not like we suddenly
solved police brutality problems no we
solved it or solved the truth
in communities yeah it's done harley and
zach a couple of ways
but but i do think that
uh
this is a really compelling solution
that can at least get us a step closer
to where we want to be as a world yeah
tool the toolbox anything that keeps
cops from bringing out their weapon more
often should be a good thing um
absolutely as long as they can you know
there are times when weapons are needed
and i think cops should have the um
ability and training to know when and
how to do that but
there should be way more options and
it's interesting because one of the i
would say valid parts of the defund the
police movement because i think there
there's the part of the defund the
police movement that's truly
abolitionism where they say hey we want
to defund
we want to get rid of police forces and
then there's a part of the defund the
police movement that will say no no
we're just saying like less funding
you know we don't and and then something
that i find very legitimate which is
cops shouldn't be responding to mental
health calls necessarily or there's all
sorts of scenarios in which you have if
you have other sorts of task forces so
to speak that can respond to different
situations we'd be better off and i
agree with that and i see this is
actually part of that as well which is
now if you have a cop responding to a
mental health situation
instead of getting aggressive with that
person or feeling like they have to
punch them to subdue them which you
should never feel but happens and i
frankly understand
like you
you now have training to
safely handle somebody who's having a
mental health crisis or or outbreak or
trying to attack you because they're
mentally ill uh so there's just so much
to this that i i mean we've given our
cops 20 weeks of training a gun a stick
and a taser and said go keep us safe
like there's it's just gonna get better
than this it's crazy
and you can
call this radical to say but i think
there's a
there's just a better way to keep us
safe i genuinely think i i don't i don't
see i don't know who could look at these
results and look at these numbers and
like offhand be like i completely
disagree with this
the pushback i see is people who
believe
or who think that
cops inherently get into it
for
bad violent reasons which by the way
exists right you have people who are
sadistic for whom
being a cop then becomes a compelling
path and you do have higher percentages
of white supremacy in in
military and cops etc right
but i i think to paint the whole police
force that way is totally off base but
there are people who who see it that way
so if you're somebody who sees it like
that then you're probably opposed to
this because you support abolitionism
other than that who could be opposed to
this i mean the numbers are really
really striking and it just makes sense
like it given it just makes sense yeah
well look longer training theoretically
and a heavier investment training would
weed out the nazis and the shitty people
so
um theoretically
anyway
so wanted to bring that to y'all's
forefront because look more into it
watch the bryant gumball piece i i
really would love to see more of a
movement around this thank you again
kevin for bringing this to our attention
i love it and keep dming us or keep
adding us on twitter with new stuff
because there's stuff that this is
remarkable news in my opinion it's a
cool like both the report was cool and
this jiu jitsu piece is cool and it's
not cutting through the mainstream
enough so we're hoping to contribute
that will fuel that fire okay
last thing about clothes so we are not a
um
we're not a bougie podcast or bougie
people but we do have bougie some bougie
friends and i want to give a shout out
to uh
our former traveling press secretary
eric sanchez who's very bougie love your
death brother um
and randy jones who's less bougie he's
from west virginia but he likes the
bouge too uh he was our political
director on the presidential campaign
they sent us a bottle champagne
we were holding this podcast but now we
are here we are i love you guys we love
you both and i mean you want to talk
about just amazing people so sanchez
lives in new orleans he is currently
evacuated his home for hurricane ida and
amidst all of that
sense of shampoo a bottle of champagne
which is just so special
yeah i actually they're just fantastic
but i don't know where his address is
because he's evacuated guy what a guy
ready jones we love you both we're
drinking champagne to you right now
now here's the deal and i want to close
this because carly i had a fight on this
a little couple fight for you
i don't even know what this fight is i
don't know what you're going to try and
argue
no you know i know vaguely the topic but
i don't understand your argument we so
we're in saint lucia and um i'll leave
the name of the resort um we tried to
find like an all-exclusive just like
turn off for two weeks and as we record
a podcast turning on um
and the first resort was
you know i think they're struggling with
kovid but it was like not great like the
food was tough here's how i would
describe it it felt like they had their
heyday in like the 1980s and like it was
a really nice resort then and they just
like haven't really updated it maybe
like the early childhood since then fine
all right yeah it's it hasn't been four
years
and carly said this place is chintzy
and
i being an idiot apparently don't know
what that word means or is and so
carly's not happy she said this place
chintzy
and
i didn't know what chintzy meant i think
i was describing the bedding i said the
bedding was the bedding scene whatever
and i said what does chintzy mean and
she said it means i said cheap and
unsubstantial
perfect but was pretty close so for me
i'm like well why don't you say the word
cheap or i'm substantial and this is our
relationship in a nutshell i think
because instead of
having a rational conversation around
whether or not we should find a new
resort and like problem solving around
that we're debating whether or not it's
okay to use ict vocab word
to describe your discomfort i did find
us a new resort you did great and we use
the word chintzy and this is my thing
and this is where i'm gonna go off bit
i understand sat vocab words
and they're important for your testing i
guess but i don't understand their use
in real life because why would one use a
word like chintzy where the vast
majority of people don't understand what
that word means when it just means cheap
use the word
no because everyone knows what cheap
means and no one cares about the
artistic nuance of your [ __ ] phrase
no no no because cheap and chintzy are
they're slightly different i know
there's a whole bunch of different
things but they mean the same thing
exactly
in the definition this is so stupid
i don't even know what your argument is
that people should use the most the
simplest most reductive word in any
scenario we should just not anything we
should divide everyday conversations
sure we should devolve as a species to
having less nuance in our you and i talk
all the time about the problem in the
press and their inability to capture
nuance or to understand things in gray
terms and now you're arguing that we
should simplify our language to its like
most
to only the simplest words and get and
have less nuance in our language it's so
crazy
and then my second point is think of all
these other languages right like shade
and freud is is a common word that the
united states like english speakers have
adopted but that's a german word that
means when you revel in somebody else's
misery no one knows that word okay
but my point being that that's that
actually is a
feeling that people have right reveling
in somebody else's misery yeah saying
revelation in somebody else's misery is
a much longer way of saying it than
shane freud
not by that much my point my point with
all this is that you have other
languages
have words for
feelings
situations that we can't express in
english and i think it would be great
to only increasingly be able to ex to
verbalize those things and to have words
to describe those things so i i'm just
the argument that we should all like
just make our language simpler and
simpler and simpler and by the way
why do you get to draw the line because
there are people who are who have a less
formed vocab than you do like is just
nuts i truthfully if i'd known this is
gonna be the full debate i just would
have said no cause i don't wanna
embarrass you this badly wow look at
that i think she's putting me in a
casket well i'm sorry that no one gives
a [ __ ] about your ivy league education
and the fantasy
we use the word cheap chintzy's not a
word people understand and every time
you use it you're either making someone
feel dumb or we waste more time by
someone saying hey what do you mean by
chelsea
hey you didn't i interrupted you you say
cheap what do you mean by chintzy say i
meant cheap and i'm just unsubstantiated
or cheap in a poor quality and then my
natural reaction why didn't we say that
was like well because chintzy's the more
apt word like is it because you know
what we have to re-explain it every time
and this is the problem you're evolving
too far there is a hot medium i agree
with you that i should not be the one
drawing the line but someone has to and
no one's taking the bull by a horns so
i'm saying chintzy is probably where the
line starts this is trying to figure out
what's next this is truly madness i mean
i guess you guys can tell us whether or
not you think i should i don't know be
allowed to use the word ginseng by the
way you used the word apt as you're
describing me and like
like i said apt when did i use apt
tape thank god we have the tape whatever
he said he's a more apt word than saying
cheap and unsubstantiated which you're
right it is more apt like i said that
doesn't sound like me
well because chintzy's the more apt word
like is it
anyway oh i'm so glad that this fight
that we're now having is recorded
because this is what i deal with but
usually it's not recorded so people i
can't force you to see that you said
that you're talking about our
relationship in a nutshell don't let her
think she won folks don't let her get
away with chintzy you've gotta be
kidding me you gotta be kidding me
anyway we love you guys we'll see you
next thursday happy labor day for those
of you who celebrate that whatever that
means we'll be celebrating in lucha with
eric sanchez and randy jones also i
really want to say thank you to everyone
who listens to this i'm like truly like
i'm so grateful that i know we're not
yang and uh i'm just really really
grateful to all of you who listen and
who dm me and who engage with the show
like i can't tell you how happy it makes
me and and how grateful i am to to all
of you and uh so anyways we do love you
and we know that you're you're here for
um they're here for your vocab words we
know that
you guys enjoy the week cheers cheers
[Music]
you